System
Surrounded by chaos
It is like a tree
The evolutionary incubator of primates
Tree, with snakes around
This is the scene
Fire Stove, For Primitive Tribes
And the horror created by forests
Which extends away from the light that is spread by the fire
It is a discovered land
In the face of a land not set foot
This is also a primitive model
You can not be in such a situation
Even if you are among friends
You take this discovered land
This is not quite true what actually happens you are about friends
they
They carefully reveal new parts of themselves all the time
As if they were blowing up elements
Small of the unknown land
Constantly if they do not?
what happens?
You will feel weary and will be looking for new guys
We know that there is empirical data
Related to
Intimate relationships There is a nice study
I have long been looking at the sentiment rate
Positive to negative
Which was the most productive in long-term relationships
In favor of the success of these relations and the answer was,
Of course it depends on how you calculate
Incident and how will measure
Positive and negative emotions
If we turn a blind eye to this
The result is that you are in a relationship
You only had five positive reactions versus one negative reaction
The relationship will end this very negative
But, if you have more than eleven interactions
Eleven positive interactions versus one negative reaction
The relationship
You will also end up believing, my God
This is really strange strange why this happens?
Would not we wish 100 positive interactions for one negative interaction?
The answer is
What makes you believe that you want the relationship to be happy!
Or at least, happy at all times and why do you think so?
It's definitely not so you know it too!
I bet you there is no one in this room
Only one day someone has refused it
He was nice to him over and over!
Something in this sense, the person of "you are more watered than necessary rojool"
Something that way you want someone you can match
Then suddenly bite you! And you feel .. Oh did you know this exciting
I never expected it!
Werbkk it up to .. Tnjt yourself thinking about it
This is one of the things that keeps you really tied to the relationship
The reason for this is that you want a relationship in your life
Not because you want to be happy in now and moment
But because you want to live a high quality life on the stretch
So many decades you are looking for someone
You can compete with someone who will push you further
You already have someone who will often try you and hardcore
For your hobbies this will make you angry
Etc. You know, and angry, and may retaliate
Etc. But you do not want to believe
You are perfect in your current situation
Partly because, who would like to accompany those who misled this greatness!